i remember these cookies being the
absolute perfect cookies just like my
grandma bonnie hey i'm alex i'm a tasty
producer and today i'm going to show you
how to make my grandma bonnie's famous
recipe for dream cookies so when i think
about my grandma these cookies
immediately come to mind they were her
signature recipe and one of my favorite
treats growing up these cookies are
similar to a shortbread but they are a
little bit different because they have a
secret ingredient that ingredient is
baker's ammonia so baker's ammonia is
great for getting really crisp cookies
and crackers which is why it's sometimes
used today so it's kind of like the old
school baking powder i guess it makes
sense that my grandma used it
the only downside of it is it's horrible
smell i'm not kidding it smells really
bad don't smell it
oh you want to make sure you're creaming
the butter and sugar together long
enough until it gets more fluffy in
texture all of the other ingredients in
this cookie are pretty classic so this
month is women's history month and i
wanted to find a special way to honor my
grandma bonnie and other special women
in my life if you were to look up like
the definition of a grandma it would be
my grandma bonnie she is just the cutest
person ever grandma bonnie exemplifies
exactly what it means to be a strong
woman she's someone who is hard-working
she loved what she did she made time to
raise her family and she made some bomb
cookies too
what's so special about these cookies is
how delicate and light they are but
still crispy and buttery and just
they're the best when you're shaping
these cookies they're actually going to
be pretty small my grandma specifies
that the dough should be no bigger than
a walnut very specific grandma you can
pop that dough ball right on a greased
baking sheet and then use the back of a
measuring cup and press lightly into the
ball of dough
[Music]
now it's time for topics my grandma
would always put three little chocolate
chips right in the center of the dough
now it seems like there's not a lot of
surface to work with here but just
squeeze them on i feel so lucky to have
a job that i absolutely love but i
wouldn't be here if it weren't for all
the amazing women who encouraged me to
chase my dreams now these cookies are
pretty tiny but that just means you can
eat a lot more of them i love
celebrating the strong women in my life
and women's history month is just an
extra excuse to celebrate all that girl
power there's nothing like these cookies
they're rich and buttery but still light
and crisp ah brings me right back to
grandma's house
[Music]
i know my grams is watching this right
now and i just want to say i love you so
much and i hope i made you proud this
one's for you grandma so legend has it
this was actually used to wake
women up if they had swooned
trust me it smells that bad oh yes
[Music]
you